hey guys don't look at me it's a scene
and today we're gonna be opening up a
mystery a bag of apple goodies so Belkin
sent me a bunch of things and I don't
even know what's in here I just kind of
tossed them all into this bag so it'll
be an exciting surprise so let's just
dive right in and see what our first
item is gonna be oh this is interesting
it's a case and a stand for your Apple
pencil so I'm gonna be honest with you I
don't remember the last time I've used
my Apple pencil because I don't really
ever use my abalones
but I know a lot of people I have so
many friends who are incredible
illustrators and it's basically like
their lifeline like this is something
that they use absolutely every day with
the iPad pro I'm not an illustrator so
this for me is not something that I
would use on a daily basis if I could
use this on my iPhone yeah I would
definitely use it but I can't if I could
use this on my macbook touchpad yeah I
would use it but it basically is
rendering itself useless until Apple
will let us use more things with it it's
like hey here's this really cool
technology that will only work with one
thing mmm but this looks cool this is
something that honestly is a real great
idea Wow yeah this is neat this is where
you'll put your Apple pencil oh it opens
up too so you can take it with you this
is what is pretty sweet because I've
already lost the attachment to this and
it has like a little area so that you
can put replacement tips and replacement
will other tip I think that's that's
sweet that is a really good idea
I mean how many of you guys are
illustrators how many of you guys
actually do use your Apple pencil is
this something that you would use
because if I did use this every day this
would be perfect if I would know where
my freakin pencil was I could travel
with it I'm into it
so far we'll one-for-one in the mystery
box bag let's move down towards the
bottom
I feel something smaller oh it's another
Apple pencil it's a stand support for
your Apple pencil again you know I wish
I wish I have more uses for it oh yeah
we definitely made a mark there will Deb
this packaging is incredible it's very
very nice very very nice Belkin oh this
has a nice weight to it what's that it's
kind of like a little like I can see
through it it's got a little hole there
it is I mean it's pretty it's pretty
simple but it's got a nice weight to it
that looks really great so far we've got
two things through the Apple pencil so
they're both cool I'm more of a fan of
this because I do travel a lot so if you
don't travel this could be something
that's might be a little bit better for
you I've got it I've got the next one oh
look at this I have never used a
third-party Apple watch strap before
I've only used she ones from Apple good
oh wait oh shoot for the 38 that's right
I don't have some friends that have a 38
it'll still strap on but the ends won't
be the same size so it's not gonna fit
properly it basically just feels like
the silicon version of the Apple watch I
really like I love that light blue color
I'm not gonna take this one out since I
don't have a 38 I would like to save it
for somebody who could use it next
this tenant stronger it's basically USB
to lightning cable but it looks like
it's a super adorable one because let me
tell you what I know you guys probably
had this problem a lot of the Apple
cables they do tend to fail especially
if you're kind of abusive and I'm
definitely abusive with traveling with
daily use you know pulling the thing out
of the wall by the core but you should
never ever do yeah we all do it and if
you don't then you're a better person
than me bunch of different colors my
bunch I mean four there's a gold silver
the rose gold and the black I've got the
black version her next video is gonna be
she broke the cord that couldn't be
broken the I know oh this is a nice it's
like a like a braided loth type texture
so here's the thing this is a lightning
cable and my fingers are crossed for USB
see on the next iPhone I am ready
I feel like it was just yesterday that I
was super upset that the new GoPros for
USB see charging because I was just
finally getting almost everything
converted to USB micro and now here we
are within a year we're all USB see baby
except for that iPhone so let's get with
it but this is nice this is so strong
this is something that I feel like I
could take out with the wilderness and
if I needed to survive
I could I could definitely hunt an
animal down with this and you know
string it up and about its feet okay
[Music]
this is what we're talking about if I
needed to survive okay I grew up in
Pennsylvania we hunted for our food and
then the food that we hunted we ate it
it's like if I had to abridge a gap
between I don't know one tree to a next
tree there is a pond in between I could
string this up like it's incredibly
strong like travel survival bag for sure
we still got free things to go oh oh
baby this is an Apple watch iPhone
charger it says it will charge your
Apple watch
eight times money milliamps are you
sixty seven hundred milliamps cool cool
cool check this out
oh this something oh let's open you up
it looks like the ring doorbell I have
yet to see a portable charger that has a
built-in Apple watch charger like this
is pretty awesome
so props that's nice it does charge
micro USB which is good
there's our ports it has one USB port
see we want to charge your iPhone but
this is the real winner if you do have
an Apple watch that's cool that's a real
win oh yes 42 millimeter baby I'm making
a huge mess
thankfully my sister out of my dog or he
would be up here going nuts that looks
good so the problem with the 48
millimeter is most of the bands that are
made for it are way bigger because they
assume that you have a bigger wrist
whereas my wrists are extremely small
but that looks really good I'm actually
quite surprised I have not even tried
experimenting with other bands on this
ceramic watch since I got it yeah I'm ah
I'm on the last one so it's as tight as
it can go he's got one more item and
it's not okay
scratch resistant anti
so we've been kind of iffy about having
clear iPhone cases because I've had them
before in the past but a lot of stuff
usually ends up falling inside of it and
then it just looks kind of disgusting
but I'm down to try feels like it's a
pretty flexible material let's try it
out I was so excited about getting a
jet-black iPhone but like I didn't
really ever get to enjoy it being
jet-black cuz I didn't want it to get
smudged or scratched so that looks
pretty cool does it look pretty cool I
guess we'll never know what I actually
said at the end of this video because
here I am ready to just edit I edited
the whole thing and I get to the end of
the video and it cuts off where we ended
this sounds pretty cool oh that looks
pretty cool the worst part about cameras
that don't have a flip-out screen is you
basically are just you know a throwing
stuff against the wall and since that's
a picture it sticks but what I did say
was I'm not a fan of clear cases which
is one of the reasons that I didn't end
up keeping the red iPhone is because the
only way that I really would have been
able to enjoy the red iPhone if I liked
the color red would be to use a clear
case and I don't like clear cases
because crap gets stuck behind them so
that's that's really it I think that's
all I said I probably said I hope that
you enjoyed this video thanks for
watching a few things like that a huge
thank you to Belkin for sending me all
these goodies and since I shot this
video I have been an absolute huge fan
of this charger I have used it almost
every day since and I actually shot this
video a while ago so that's been quite a
while but it's it's incredible it's
great it's super small I can fit it on
the side of my backpacks just like that
I can't judge my Apple watch and
anything else via USB so this has been
super cool and I've never had a battery
charger with its like this shape before
so it fits in smaller purses and things
like that but thank you guys for
watching this video I hope that you guys
didn't enjoy it
this is the end so that's it we'll see
you later
[Music]